all right did you watch Modern Family's
Halloween episode last night the death
that we heard was coming finally happen
big spoiler if you haven't seen it yet
cover your ears I'm gonna give you all
just a second all right there and
Mitchell's mom didi played by Shelley
long passed away peacefully in her sleep
for the character because she affects so
many others on this show I get it but I
don't you okay okay I'm all right
meanwhile Sofia vegara is okay actually
she is better than okay I'll be in
beauty tops the Forbes list of TV's
highest-paid actresses for the seventh
year in a row Sophia's forty two point
five million dollar payday is no joke
while most of her earnings are from
endorsement deals she still makes an
estimated half-million dollars a show
really that's pretty impressive
meanwhile banking a record $900,000 in
episode the Big Bang Theory's kaley
cuoco at number two close behind grey's
Anatomy's Ellen Pompeo who revealed
earlier this year that she's now the
highest-paid TV actress in a drama shows
a tremendous money maker let's be honest
it makes a fortune for everybody making
slightly smaller fortunes Law & Order
SVU smoosh Iike Hargitay and Modern
Family's Julie Bowen oh my god tied at
number 6 Big Bang stars Mayim Bialik and
melissa rauch who each rake in half a
million dollars in episode cheers for
Kerry Washington it paid to play Olivia
Pope on scandal before the series ended
earlier this year she brought home 11
million bucks candles also cashing in
homelands clear danes and rounding out
the top 10
former NCIS star pauley perrette I'm not
coming back in May Polly say goodbye to
the show after 15 years of playing crime
fighter Abby Sciuto I will always be so
proud of everything Abby
you
[Applause]
[Music]